you see the IQ tests where it says that
men are on one end or the other end of
the IQ distribution women are all
gathered in the middle and you know I
hear you maybe there's some truth to
that but you know I just don't believe
it sorry and and this is the this is the
thing like we can look at what the the
institutions are telling us and what the
media is telling us or I can look at
what's in front of my eyes man I'm sorry
but as women we just lead we make
decisions emotionally what do you think
guys if we were so smart the most
important decision of our life which is
picking a husband don't you think we'd
be smart about picking one like
seriously like don't you I think we
would be smart and think to ourselves
let me pick a good husband instead of
making a baby with a drug dealer or a
guy that's cheated on every single
girlfriend he's ever had or a guy that